let's let's let's let's crank this up to
11. daily mail says u.s official warns
cornered russian leader could use small
nukes on ukrainian cities in worst case
scenario after kremlin officials
privately denounced putin's cluster f
invasion with his forces bogged down in
snow and minus 20 c freeze on the way
i kind of want to just say at this point
bullish like all of it they're coming
out and they're like
yeah russia could do a bio attack there
could be nukes and i'm like okay look
look look hold on
when they talked about the invasion i
said starting to sound like chicken
little and then there was an invasion so
far be it for me i have no i have no
moral standing at this point to claim
putin won't be using nukes because i was
certainly wrong by him invading kiev but
at this point i'm just like yo you've
beaten us over the head screaming about
the escalation and putin is crazy over
and over again can we just chill for a
minute yeah well i mean look the moral
of the story of the boy who cried wolf
is not that those stupid village people
didn't believe him the one time he was
telling the truth
is that he kept lying and so he lost all
of his credibility that's the exact case
with the media maybe they maybe this is
the one time where they have real
information about something that's
actually gonna happen
well they did phrase it as it may it's
their fault it's their fault that people
don't believe them because all they do
is lie sheamus
we can get this project done in a half
an hour let's do it you should draw up
we'll work together we'll make a book
called the democrats who cried russia
and it'll be a children's book
not really it'll be like but like
where like the first few pages explained
russiagate and i was all fake yeah and
then and then in the end when the
democrats finally came out and screamed
rush is going to invade no one believed
them and then putin invaded and attacked
that's 100 percent do it that would be
funny 100 do it yeah i'd love it the
democrat who cried russia
after seven years we just didn't care
anymore or like they're like yeah the
media that cried anything
yeah the media that cried racism or
fascism or whatever i don't know you
guys so look i don't necessarily think
it's wrong i want to add one one thing
to this story too this idea that
vladimir putin is dying so this is
something that's been reported over the
past several days they're claiming he's
got terminal bowel cancer
and i'm just kind of like you know look
he does look a little sickly but he
could be getting old but to claim that
there's like there's there's scant
evidence it's an anonymous source
claiming he's got terminal bowel cancer
we've had great luck with those
anonymous sources over the past couple
of years i don't i don't know if i i
don't i definitely don't believe that
either because did you see the video of
putin that went viral a couple months
ago of him playing hockey oh really no
yeah um it's really funny because he's
like he's playing in a hockey game and
all of the other players on the ice are
just like letting him score of course
letting them like
but i mean he was playing goals i mean
he was playing if he could do that i
don't really think that he would be
terminally ill yeah but he also just
take time off
did he know yeah a little while ago he
took like a few weeks to a couple months
off i don't know but you remember do you
remember like i forget when this was
this was probably over a year ago when
there were reports going around that kim
jong-un was on his deathbed that was cnn
too cnn was like reporting like it was
cnn reporting that kim jong-un was on
his deathbed and basically just caused
an international incident and that
turned out to be false you know what's
funny
we got these reports about you know a
cornered putin will use nukes a dying
putin is dangerous mad vlad and it's
like
the media is going to end the world do
you guys if the world ends it'll be
because there is a hysteria driven by
media who wanted that one last click
yeah i've got another example do you
guys remember the time that the media
lied to us about every single thing they
ever told us for the entire time they
existed
that was called my life yeah good times
i feel like it's it's also not just that
they lie it's that they completely
ignore real problems that matter a lot
more to americans so they've been
obsessed with this invasion in ukraine
we have an invasion at our southern
border right now but the media portrays
that as compassionate that that that
that america just that the bind
administration just allows this to
happen also we have an invasion in libya
and in iraq that we're perpetrating
right now that you don't see much
much of this talking about it
unfortunately you should do a bit where
cnn hires jesse smallett
and then everyone's just like we trust
him i mean it's similar most believable
guy redemption it's his redemption
and he can he can talk he can always he
can be holding a subway sandwich as he's
always reporting the news reporting live
for mega country because you know i'll
keep saying it every single time like
right now i can just be like the media
that beli the people who believe jesse
smallett are lecturing me about bio labs
in ukraine yeah not gonna happen this
time ladies and gentlemen so the thing
about these news articles this says
western intelligence suggests they're
not saying that it's real they're just
pointing out that the intelligence
suggests it and then the other one is
like he may use or he could use people
people could throw lasers out of his
arms and shoot them too people familiar
with the matter have said that putin
might use nukes
my favorite thing is people familiar
with a person's thinking yeah like how
does that
well i'm familiar with the media's
thinking and i think they're completely
full of it i'm familiar with ian's
thinking and i'm reporting that he plans
on buying rocks uh he may be right
i i'm reporting ian maybe rolling a 20
at some point let me let me give a shout
out to our possibly i just i just i just
remembered a great example of one of
those stories uh this i gotta give a
shout out to my friend ben williamson
who uh used to work for mark meadows and
there was a story like a little while
ago um when the media was like someone
familiar with mark meadows is thinking
and ben is like it was his senior
advisor and he just goes with all due
respect to the person familiar with his
thinking this story is [ __ ] yeah
i want to give a shout out to our good
friends daily wire who very very
carefully crafted this headline in two
ways
mad vlad western intelligence suggests
putin terminally ill terminally ill
reports so what they're basically saying
is first of all we're not saying he's
terminally ill and those who are
claiming it are only kind of claiming it
so the daily wires really hedged this
article quite a bit yeah basically it
seems like everybody's kind of like i
don't think he's sick
you know i got to be honest though i
mean you know maybe
regardless of whether or not he's
actually got bowel cancer or anything
like that dude is 69 average life
expectancy is what 72 in russia i
imagine that's a stressful freaking job
too yeah
exactly i'd imagine in russia it's
probably lower right maybe
someone google that yeah yeah i'll pull
it up i think i think there's a good
possibility it's not necessarily about
him being terminally ill but him being
like
i'm old and before i pass i'm gonna see
russia you know return to its former
glory it could also be him understanding
that he is never going to have the
opportunity of a leader as completely
inept as joe biden being in office ever
again he probably knows that joe is not
going to last the full term so he wants
to get it taken care of now looks like
russian life expectancy 66 years old for
a man 77 for a woman
so he's he's passed his his you know his
averages world health organization going
off what sheamus just said what was that
article you were showing me right before
the show where like the saudi that house
they did people like this didn't take
i'm trying to remember what it was um
hold on one sec i think that um
biden was trying to make a call to putin
and he wouldn't take a call from putin
but he did take a call from the uae or
um
the uae took calls from putin or
whatever
yeah there we go yep yeah it's wild wait
so putin denied putin denied uh biden's
call yes come on man you've got a soul
man it's wild but is is uh this guy is
there's a zero percent chance that ever
happened no there's no
i was saying this in the day the thing i
love about that story is biden thinks it
makes him look good to say like i i went
to that foreign leader and i called him
mean
you have no soul man i think that's what
i said russia's like is that it man it's
like it's always okay it's like you kind
of want your adversaries to think you're
mean don't you yeah yeah there's also so
many of those like similar stories with
biden where he claims he did all of
these things that he never like he
claimed like he always claims that he
like marched he was arrested while
protesting with nelson mandela right
like that never happened he's like oh
man i was i was there but it's it's the
mandela effect man you guys you're all
right be there to experience it right
this would be a great short film is
biden's mandela
actually happened all these stories are
real check it out the corn pop story the
mandela story also he also hold on the
the speech he gave in the 80s yeah but
then something happened with a large
hadron collider yeah and then joe
biden's like standing there i'm a victim
of time travel a rift opens up and he's
like whoa come on man and then he gets
sucked through into a reality where he
didn't do any of these things well putin
banged his straight razor on the curb to
get it rusty put it in a rain barrel to
get it rusty and then it wasn't just a
dream
let's pitch to the daily wire a sci-fi
about joe biden traveling through the
multiverse
it's interstellar but just with joe
biden yeah
oh my gosh and like for some reason he's
interested like matthew mcconaughey is
the same role doing the same things but
it's joe biden in every other capacity
for some reason
come on man traveling through uh
traveling through uh other dimensions no
malarkey he comes from a universe where
people like still frequently use the
phrase malarkey and that's why he's cold
he's fighting everything he's doing all
these wars because he's trying to
restore the original timeline and
vladimir putin's trying to stop him so
it was like putin and and biden met at a
young age and and worked together and
then had a falling out when when you
know the large hadron collider goes off
and sends them into different dimensions
and putin trying to stop him
i mean it could work it could work as a
sci-fi plot in his universe having hairy
legs as a sign of nobility
god harry
they get hairy in the pool
there's also the one with the the the
amtrak guy have you ever seen this one
he tells this story so he tells the
story all the time he's told it like a
bunch of times he's talking about public
transportation about how
he says about how he was a senator he
would travel to and from dc to delaware
on amtrak and like there was this guy
uh some italian dude i forget his name
who who he said like came up to him in
like 2019 or something when he was vice
president and was like and he always
like fakes the italian accent and he's
like he tells him you don't mamma mia
and he's like you know how many miles
you traveled on amtrak and he like i
forget the number of miles but it turns
out the guy died like 10 years before
before that i'm telling you it's wrong
universe oh my god i mean let's i i want
to be with you guys uh biden has like
some plates in his brain doesn't he yeah
he does does he really yeah he's like i
didn't know that he did things he had
like two aneurysms or something he did
yeah so i it's it's like honestly maybe
the real story is just much more sad it
is brain is just
not working it's genuinely sad the oh
it's genuinely sad
it but it's also terrible and worthy of
ridicule that he's president of the
united states and that no one's willing
to acknowledge that he has severe
psychological and cognitive deficits
well well you that's just a stutter you
know yeah
that's my point dude have you ever like
you ever had like a stutter that forces
you to plagiarize somebody else's speech
it's so weird when that happens remember
dude oh my gosh remember that one time
that i said poor kids are just as bright
and talented as white kids it's like i
stutter all the time
i want to tell you about this
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
that we have uh it's like wait what
that's stuttering
yeah he has the kind of tourette's where
you blurt out famous historical quotes
you can't blame him for it
but what's even sadder is that kamala
harris is even worse
with saying nothing saying a lot while
saying nothing at all it's amazing isn't
it she's not like she's not like
slurring and misspeaking as often when
she does she just says
[ __ ] that makes no sense yeah right
she'll say a whole paragraph and i feel
like there's a lot of words but i don't
know where that i don't know what you
just said i don't think i don't know and
frankly i don't think you were telling
the truth yeah i don't know no no
there's no truth to be had when you're
like stringing random words together
it's like lips
our children
and when we talk about our children
the schools
it's very important freedom you're like
what freedom i have no idea what that
means but she's standing there and she's
talking what's that meme where was like
international women's day have you seen
this one it's a great no and it's like
be brave like amelia at the bottom oh i
saw that it says speak like come along
and people are like are we really
encouraging young girls to speak like
kamala harris just laugh maniacally it's
time for us to do what we have been
doing and that time is every
day oh my gosh that's ukraine beautiful
ukraine is a country yes russia is a
country yes ukraine is a smaller country
russia invaded ukraine so basically
that's wrong is it is that what she said
yes she said that she said that on some
like radio shows yes they were like can
you break this down
the guy was hold on let me find the
quote because i would say it is time for
us to be doing what we do every day
time is not let me find the full quote
because it's actually one of the
funniest things ever and like and i so i
tweeted the video of it that day and i
had so many blue checks who got mad at
me for not including the whole thing
even though the whole thing didn't even
like make her look that much better
um but hold on let me find this yo here
it is she was like ukraine is a country
so so the the host of the show asked her
to break down what's happening in
ukraine in layman's terms and she goes
ukraine is a country in europe it exists
next to another country called russia
russia is a bigger country russia is a
powerful country russia decided to
invade a similar country called ukraine
so basically that's wrong
that's what that is
that is a third grader's history report
50 years from now and it's like and it's
like i i i didn't do the reading
i wasn't
little little jimmy do you want to read
your report my report is on the start of
world war three
ukraine was a big country but russia was
a bigger country and russia's invasion
was wrong that's an a plus right there
if i've ever heard it i wasn't aware
that the average layman in america is a
kindergarten i know right
yeah oh my gosh why is russia man i go
into a lot of detail about why russians
and russia's invasion was wrong and i'm
like i'm pretty sure the people who
listen to me can understand my argument
as to why it's wrong whether they agree
or not kamala harris
this is the craziest thing
i suppose you need to understand her
audience democrat voters they really do
need it dumbed down i guess
i don't know but it's really yeah but
she's not but that's the thing i guess
that's an example of it being dumbed
down but a lot of the times it's not
dumbing things down it's making them
really incoherent yeah well i mean what
is she saying that was like explaining
to a five-year-old yeah exactly no that
was a five-year-old explaining it yeah
did you guys see the little golden book
of kamala harris
oh gosh why but here's oh yeah for real
like so the little golden books are like
the the little elf climbed the tree and
then there's one where it's like kamala
harris is the president because she's a
woman or something like that what
sometimes people like people and
sometimes
the media wants to force you to like
someone no that's exactly right and like
you have this woman who is the first
black and female vice president and
we're supposed to celebrate this and as
as yeah and asian but we're supposed to
celebrate that as like this giant
victory for women that kamala harris is
vice president even though she was
chosen for the job specifically because
of her race and gender right after she
dropped out of the presidential race
before iowa because she was polling at
two percent in her home state and earned
no delegates and earned zero dollars he
got one right yes and like yeah and even
paul joe biden and called joe biden a
racist
and basically said that there was
validity to the claims that he was
guilty of sexual assault and he's like
you want to be my my vp man she's like
of course i do you guys uh
remember the feature om episode where
lila plays blirn's ball yes so this one
it's uh so futurama is amazing and leela
is
she keeps hitting the players it's like
baseball basically she keeps beating
them and so they're like we'll hire her
as a novelty act and she's like wow the
first female blurs ball player is like
yeah but you're like a freak show she's
like wow like
that's where we're at i guess like just
be you know and then and then they have
um
jackie
jackie robinson i guess
is actually good at the game and says
you're making us all look bad so we had
to get involved kamala harris may be the
first female vp but like isn't like that
kind of a bad thing because she's making
women look bad weren't we told that
she's the first president the first
female president yeah that's true and
jill biden said she was president as
well at this point it's canon yeah
that's canon
for the rest of time women will have to
know that the first female vice
president of this country was a very
incompetent person who was chosen
specifically because of her gender when
i like to laugh sometimes i like to
google back from right after the first
democratic debate in 2019 when kamala
harris's campaign sold t-shirts with her
picture on it when she was a kid that
said that little girl was me
they sold t-shirts of it
for saying that when she said that to
biden i triggered a whole bunch of blue
checks because i tweeted
that it would be kind of it would be
kind of uh upsetting or it would be kind
of lame if the first female president
gained the office through the death of
the president and not through the
election of the people of the country
and they all went nuts on me over this
and it was a really weird thing i'm like
why am i how am i why are you doing i'm
right you know what i mean like if the
first president is appointed and not
elected that's kind of lame like
shouldn't we be like we've done it
people have elected they've chosen to
vote for this woman instead of being
like joe biden won and he picked her and
then if he gets you know incapacitated
she became president no one picked her
no one voted for she was appointed
that would be kind of lame how do you
know people didn't vote for joe biden
because they liked kamala oh well
probably no to be to be honest though
i'm sure a lot of people did a lot of
people probably were the feminists in
the world
well but this is the thing joe biden
picked her to pander to progressives
because he promised he was going to pick
a woman of color but basically every
progressive i know really does not like
kamala you know come on really don't
like her it's true but they don't they
they claim that like joe biden all voted
for him one hundred percent like like
they're kind of like yeah
i remember watching contra points
explain why you should vote for joe
biden and i remember watching a bunch of
progressives explain why you should vote
for joe biden and their arguments were
always because trump x y or z of course
and i remember my explanation for why i
personally was voting for trump and it
was school choice it was him setting a
timeline for getting out of afghanistan
it was the the best economy of our lives
in 2019 into 2020 like there were real
tangible things he was proposing where i
was like i like those things i don't
care about joe biden he's an
establishment guy but i can give you a
real argument based on the guy i'm
choosing to vote for for the people
voting for biden they're like trump is
bad and i'm like well biden's bad too
but they vote for him anyway well he's a
product of sort of the the rabid
desire of the media of
you know permanent washington to remove
trump from power because he was the
biggest threat to the establishment's
power that we've ever seen in politics
and that's exactly what they did you
know i i think you'd be very
hard-pressed to find somebody who voted
for biden because they were very excited
to have joe biden as president that's
100 not true and
they voted for him because they were
riled up but because they were convinced
that donald trump was just this biggest
threat to democracy that ever existed
and they used they weaponized the
pandemic against him the fact that this
happened during a pandemic year and they
you know they were basically saying that
every coveted death was somebody donald
trump murdered and between like
obviously big tech and the media being
extremely biased to one side between
states uh you know completely
overhauling their voting laws because
just you know justifying it because the
pandemic you had this perfect storm
where you have this guy now who is
essentially a puppet of the
establishment that was threatened by
trump who's now ruining our country
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you